ああああああ
新年多いです
えっ
水普通にやら怒られそう
新年明けましておめでとうございます肇社長です
実家ですなのでちょっとあん
やりづらいとですそれが始まりました2020年
さあどんな年にしたいかといいますとまぁ去年の最後の方に言ったんですけども
前に児童が+なぁもうやめましょういうことでまぁヒント的なものは下がるかもしれ
ないまたねちょっとしたらたくさんあげることもあるかもしれないんですけども無理せ
ずいいとをとっていければいいなと思っておりますから是非
肇社長を見てくださる方はあ
みてくださいそして皆さんお待ちかね今年の芝でくれ
どうなるのでしょこのないよ楽しみにしてる人多いと思います今まで誰かの経路を買っ
たんですけども去年はなんと服装スーツ縛りという1年間でありましたまあ見事1年間
スーツで撮影をし続けた結果
まーすぎつなかったなぁ
ブーバーと思った1年でしたドッキリ服を選ばティパドゥラファティちょちょっとヌー
ワーカーできるか自分の中でもすごい不安は残ってるんですけどもう発表いたします
私
肇社長は
1年間
腹筋
ズームお願いします
th
本当に対するからやりましょうやってやりましょう私何を隠そう今年で27歳になり
まして
もうもうそのめちゃくちゃ若いわけじゃないんですよ若いですけどよ夏に目シートがお
菓子たくさん食っちゃうと太っちゃうしーして何よりも運動後即がちょっと深刻だなと
ここ23年思っておりましてどうすればいいのかそう
腹筋終わればいいんです
スよ
て結論にたどり着きまして前髪長く私は1年間でトータル腹筋10万回しようと思い
ますって単純な計算したんですけども
1年が365日ありますと北1で300回やろうかなと思っておりまして以前地300
たよ365日すると109,500回
9500からちょっと余分になっちゃうんですよこの旧車
500回分をちょっと動画で休みながらやっていこうかなと思っておりますちなみに1
日200ならず4回すると365日10万10回になりますが基本的に全300回です
ね一日300回目標でやっていきましょう
なんで復帰にしたかと言いますと僕知ってるとで猫背なんですよすごく
俺いやなんですここの筋肉でこの胸を支えるらしいんでずっきんやっぱきたらのって
ちょっと猫背の改善に良いということも聞きました
まぁそれだけでもないんですけどやっぱさー
払われるとさんっ
モテるじゃん a というとこですよ1年後にバギーバギーな時に言われたらとても
面白いんじゃないかなと思いまして今年は1年間腹筋が終わりたいと思いますあの
ラクじゃないからね300回腹筋やってみ今から普通になくから z 2日後試しで
やってみたんでちょっとご覧ください
どうぞよ
[音楽]
ちょっと300回もやったことないんで1回体感してみますねあとどれくらい時間が
かかるかも今年一年間かなり自由にやっていると思うんでいきます
8位の
にっ
4これいけるぞ
ます
ani
癖
ゴザ2
教授芸だけ j
ここで原クリコ60でちょっとおやおやって感じですね
[音楽]
ブーブーするんでしょやばいなぁまぁこれを5セットって考えるのができそうな気もし
ますねちょっとに行きますっ
の木 j
voodoo
たーっ
ブーバー in 伊勢
[音楽]
山ヤガー
あの
ん
まあ18分ぐらいでできましたね余裕
もう初日はきついの絶対そうだと思ってたんで社内スコッからどれだけ僕が強くなれる
んですねまた明日頑張りますでは
これやばいは1日目300回なんとかってきたんですけど
ふっ加盟のハラーがちょっとっ
a 動かないんですよ筋肉痛とかじゃなくてもう筋肉さん持つんですよ痛い
かつ筋肉に造らが入らないです名簿にこれだったろうなかあるまだ見てちょっとあっ
簿4弾ではやりましょうちょっとなんとかここを乗り切ればいきそうな気がするんです
よ見難い頑張ります
行きは
アーマって一致
[音楽]
ブーブー
やばい
た
4日
持った
[音楽]
やばい
まって本当じゃない
ナッツといった
[音楽]
やばいやばい
力
えっ
[音楽]
ビーフちゃ
ええぞ
えーどうでしょうか
2日目あんな感じですもう本当にもう無理てが後援者のこれなんか
肉なるとか起こして体壊れたらもう止まっちゃうんでまずちょっと休む日をちゃんと
つかみながら腹筋していかなきゃいけないなと思いましたあとあれだね
体のバランスをよくするためにハイキング品を鍛えないとダメなんでちょっと今年はね
そういう体とか運動に気を使った何にしようかなと思っております
[音楽]
いやーこんなんだ金原だ言っ
お子様におうっ
はいという感じでございます
[音楽]
ちょっとほんとさんになる
6しかないで来年の最後に腹筋バッキバキに割れて年末に僕が10万回腹筋している
動画が出せればいいなと思っておりますので皆さん今年も宜しくお願い致します
楽しいねぇ
me
あっはぁ